[BACKGROUND VOICES]
Lord Peter Levene >> I'm the Chairman of Lloyd's,
and it's great to join everybody. I've been
asked to try and express my view on this question
of will the world economy turn around in 2009.
I-I've always been an optimist, and would
love to answer 'yes,' but I think the realist
in me says that it's going to take a while.
I mean, unfortunately we've got these big
job layoffs being announced all over the world
at the moment-a lot of very hard working people
losing their jobs. Almost everyone who does-they're
going to have a lot less to spend on other
things which means that other people are not
going to have the jobs to go around. Somehow
this is all going to be kickstarted.
And I'm confident it'll happen but as much
as I'd love to say it's going to be fixed
by the end of this year, I don't think so.
So I am optimistic that we are going to work
very hard to try and get this right as soon
as we can, and maybe if we're standing here
next year I will have been proved wrong which
will be great, or at least we'll be on the
way by then. Very good to talk to you.